trotzdem hat für sprachakrobaten ist
Olaf Scholz ein gefundenes Fressen der
Kanzler liefert die Blaupause für
Etikettierungen geradezu frei Haus ist
so eine Kommunikation gerissen oder
angesichts vieler Krisen leichtfertig
schließlich wollen die Menschen ihrem
Regierungschef Vertrauen schenken können
von Krise zu Krise hat Scholz die Lage
im Griff jetzt in der phönix-runde
[Musik]
hammelsprung im Bundestag am Nachmittag
die Union will dass der Kanzler
zurückkommt zur aktuellen Stunde über
Energie und die Wirtschaftskrise doch
beim Zählappell also diesem hammelsprung
den Sie hier sehen da scheitert sie dazu
gleich noch mehr ja und damit herzlich
willkommen liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer bei uns meine Gäste hier im
Studio Rosalia romaniac ist Leiterin des
Hauptstadtstudios der Deutschen Welle
Ulrike Herrmann Wirtschaftsjournalistin
bei der taz hier in Berlin
Christoph Schwennicke Journalist und
Kolumnist bei T-Online und bin Alexander
es bei uns stellvertretender
Chefredakteur der Welt ja bevor wir
gleich hier in die Diskussion eintreten
den hammelsprung den sie gerade gesehen
haben der hat eine kleine Vorgeschichte
gehabt der Oppositionsführer hat ein
Statement abgegeben weil ihm gestört hat
dass der Regierungschef nicht anwesend
war
auf der Regierungsbank sitzt nicht ein
einziges Mitglied der Bundesregierung
und auch der Bundeskanzler hält es nicht
für nötig an dieser Diskussion
teilzunehmen
ja man muss allerdings auch fairerweise
sagen kurz davor war der Bundeskanzler
insgesamt 70 Minuten anwesend im
Bundestag bei der Befragung durch die
Abgeordneten Alexander der Kanzler nicht
im Parlament bei einem aktuellen
Top-Thema das was Friedrich Merz da
gerade moniert hat was sagt das über den
Führungsstil von Scholz aus oder ist das
eine lästliche Sünde also ich finde da
er ja wirklich vorher bei dieser
Befragung da war ist das für ihn
persönlich glaube ich okay das aber
tatsächlich bei so einem Kernthema
keiner außer Regierung da ist das ist
schon eine Vorlage die man als
Oppositionsführer nutzen kann und wird
März ja auch gemacht und deshalb kommt
das ja jetzt auch wieder im Fernsehen
und die Regierung hat sowieso ein Stil
der nicht ganz parlamentsfreundlich ist
also man sich anguckt die haben ja in
den letzten Tagen zum Beispiel diese
ganzen Gesetze gemacht wie wird die
Energieversorgung neu aufgebaut 600
Seiten teilweise haben die Abgeordneten
die morgens gekriegt und mussten die
abends schließen und Änderungen haben
mittendrin also das ist jetzt nicht so
dass man sagt im Parlament ist eine
wahnsinns Kompetenz und wir als
Regierung ziehen uns die sondern es ist
eher so das hauen wir da schnell durch
damit die nicht im Weg sind
der Kanzler war wahrscheinlich nicht
weit weg etwas weiter weg war der
Finanzminister der ja auch ganz wichtig
ist in diesem Zusammenhang der ist im
Moment auch freier süßen wandelnd auf
Sylt es geht ja um Inflation es geht um
einen kalten Winter und drohenden kalten
Winter um Zukunft zu Ängste hat die
Ampel das ist ja auch unser Untertitel
die Lage im Griff naja sobald man das im
Griff haben kann also man muss ja sagen
wir haben jetzt drei Krisen gleichzeitig
alles drei externe Schocks da in dieser
Häufung gab es das noch nie also erstens
Corona ist immer noch nicht vorbei
zweitens die ukraine-krise und dann was
auch oft vergessen wird gab es ja diesen
Lockdown in Shanghai der Hafen war
monatelang stillgelegt da lagen dann
drei Prozent der containerkapazitäten
monatelang vor Shanghai jetzt klingen 3%
vielleicht nicht viel
das ist aber in so einem eng getakteten
Warenverkehr wie bei den Schiffen eine
Katastrophe das stört die globalen
Lieferketten auf Monate und das muss man
jetzt alles managen und deswegen würde
ich jetzt auch gerne noch mal ein Robin
Alexander kurz widersprechen nämlich
erstens das stimmt das jetzt sehr viele
Gesetze durchs Parlament gehen aber das
sind alles krisenreaktionsgesetze also
man kann ich meine das ist ja das was
die Regierung will
Energiegesetze sind die Vorstellungen
wie die ampelenergieversorgung um also
im Prinzip haben Sie Recht ist aber für
diese Gesetze konkret das war dann was
sie sich selber vorgenommen haben
knapp wird und man ja deswegen
erneuerbare Energie braucht so und das
zweite was sie auch noch sagen wollte
ist ich glaube das Scholz deswegen nicht
im Parlament war weil märz ein
durchsichtiges Spiel spielt diese Art
von leitanträgen die jetzt immer kommen
wo er sich dann äußern will ja
Leitantrag der Woche das kommt nämlich
von oben von der Fraktionsführung und
soll dann den Kanzler vorführen das
kommt nicht von unten von den
Parlamentariern so und das Scholz
Verlust auf dieses durchsichtige Spiel
hat das kann ich jetzt wirklich
verstehen aber man jetzt der
Bundeskanzler führt ja das Wort Respekt
sehr oft im Mund damit hat er fast im
Alleingang die die Bundestagswahl nicht
unwesentlich mitentschieden zu sein
Gunsten aber gehört dazu dem Wort
Respekt auch Respekt vor den eigenen
Aufgaben eines Kanzlers einer
Bundesregierung oder anders gefragt
mangelt es der Ampelkoalition an Respekt
vor ihren eigenen Pflichten ich würde
die Meinung nicht teilen also ich glaube
teile die Meinung Ehe dass die Regierung
unerwartete Weise von
Krisen steht die vor denen wir seit
eigentlich noch nie so gestanden haben
und das alles zu managen nach innen und
nach außen gerade
in diesem Spannungsfeld würde ich nicht
sagen dass mangelt an Respekt vor den
eigenen Aufgaben also wenn man sich
jetzt anschaut welche entlastungspakete
was alles
die geschnürt wird der Blick aus dem
Ausland sieht anders aus als der Blick
den man vielleicht hier im Land selber
hat also das würde wie ist da der
ausländische Blick auf die auf die
deutsche Politik auf den Kanzler es ist
teilweise ein bisschen ambivalent
natürlich geht es auch darum wie stellen
sich die Bundesregierung und auch der
Kanzlei gegenüber der Ukraine der Hilfe
die Waffenlieferungen andererseits hat
man auch sage ich mal mit Respekt zu
kennt dies genommen dass diese Regierung
einige Tabubrüche zu Beginn gemacht hat
Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine 100
Milliarden Paket die ganzen Entlastungen
das ist schon auch etwas was man achtet
natürlich ist trotzdem dieses Stil den
Zögerlichkeit die Form wie man führt wie
diese versprochene
Führungsanspruch aus umgesetzt wird da
hat man natürlich schon irgendwie
einiges noch an wünschen gerade im Osten
aber ich würde sagen
alle wissen welche Rolle Deutschland
spielt und wie finanzieren in Europa
vieles an Deutschland hängt und daher
also
auch Kritik an der Person an der
Kommunikation an den Handlungen des
Regierungschefs agiert der Bundeskanzler
zu wenig geschmeidig müsste er mehr
situativ reagieren also abwarten in dem
Fall wo abwarten sinnvoll ist und
schnelles Handeln gefährlichen umgekehrt
zu packend wenn abwarten eben
tatsächlich eigentlich nachteilig ist
ist das
wäre er wenn er etwas geschmeidiger wäre
würde er sich dann diese Titel wie
scholzsomat und trotzdemat ersparen bei
mir ist er manchmal eher zugeschmeidig
vor allem auch rhetorisch zugeschmeidig
das ist ja eines auch unserer Probleme
dass er auf Fragen entweder gar nicht
antwortet oder so wachsweich dass man
mit der Antwort auch nicht viel anfangen
kann ich sehe das Problem dieser
Regierung im Moment weniger in der in
den im substanziellen handeln als primär
in der Performance so wie es neudeutsch
gesagt rübergebracht wird und da hat
Olaf Scholz tatsächlich
Defizite ganz klare Defizite also
Kommunikation ist nicht seine
Lieblingsdisziplin da macht ihm zum
Beispiel Wirtschaftsminister Habig
wirklich vor wie es geht denn bei dem
kann man ja beim beim Denken quasi zu
gucken und er führt einen durch all
seine hin und her ist am Ende zu dem
Ergebnis wo uns gerne haben möchte das
ist guter politischer erklärstil und das
hat ist Olaf Scholz so nicht gegeben mai
was was der was der
Oppositionsführer gemacht hat ist okay
das ist schon schnell ein Punkt das ist
in Ordnung man merkt ihm glaube ich
selber dabei an dass es auch eine
gespielte Empörung ist jeder der davor
bringt das ich erinnere mich an einen
Fall aber da war Scholz auch nicht da
auch eine wichtige Debatte da war auf
dem Weg nach Japan kein unwichtiger
Besuch wenn man weiß dass in dem Moment
diese Koalition geschmiedet werden
mussten in Bezug auf Russland also ich
würde sagen der Substanz ist es gar
nicht so schlecht
aber es bringt es nicht besonders gut
rüber und dann kommt dazu ab und zu so
Anfälle so quartalsanfälle von von
Hochmut Hoffart war mein schönes altes
Wort ist leider ausgestorben aber das
trifft eigentlich am besten und dann
passen irgendwie diese großen Sprüche
scheinbar oder tatsächlich nicht zu
dieser Performance hat Scholz die Lage
im Griff ist ja der die Frage die wir
stellen wollen in der Sendung Alexander
welche Antwort gibt denn der heutigen
Nachmittag im Bundestag darauf also die
Befragung der Bundesregierung gehen wir
gleich noch genauer ein auch die
Aktuelle Stunde auch das was im Moment
im Parlament Christoph Schwenninger hat
von Performance gesprochen abläuft hat
Scholz die Lage im Griff also in dieser
regierungsbefragung habe ich keine
substanziellen Neuigkeiten erspürt
wichtiger ist glaube ich das was
sozusagen jetzt in diesen Tagen und
Nächten substanziell verhandelt wurde
und die Regierung überlegt sich ja was
machen wir im Herbst Winter wenn Putin
uns das Gas abk ja wird jetzt schon
runter geschraubt Nord Stream 1 die
Pipeline wird bald gewartet also
turnusmäßig ist die zehn Tage zu und es
gibt Leute in der Bundesregierung die
damit rechnen dass die gar nicht wieder
aufgehen so dann die politische Wartung
die dann ab 21 Juli aufmachen so und
dann ist jetzt die Frage was macht man
und da lagen ja verschiedene Optionen
auf dem Tisch und im Ausland werden auch
unterschiedliche Dinge gemacht was
schlimm Manuel macront heute in großen
Energieversorger einfach mal
verstaatlicht und die Regierung hat sich
jetzt entschieden einerseits die Gesetze
so zu ändern dass sie einsteigen können
in die Energieversorger wenn die in
Schwierigkeiten geraten und andererseits
eine Art Umlagesystem zu machen das also
wenn ein dieser Versorger ein großer
Schwierigkeiten ist der nicht seinen
Kunden alles überhelfen kann sondern
dass der Preis nur bis zu einem
bestimmten Punkt steigt und dann soll
die da sozialisiert wird
und das ist was interessantes das kann
man aus gerechtigkeitspunkten verstehen
die Frage ist nur wir müssen ja weniger
Gas verkaufen also die Regierung muss
eigentlich die Frage beantworten wie
kriegen wir die Leute zum Sparen und die
Antwort von Robert habe ich verstanden
er hat gesagt nicht mehr lange Duschen
kleinere Fernseher also der so ein
Appell
Scholz hat diesen Appell ausgeschlagen
ist ein Interviews gefragt worden wollen
sie auch solche Tipps mal gesagt nö von
Christian
habe ich dazu noch gar nichts gehört
also ich habe nur den die Position eines
Teils der Regierung verstanden und das
ist dann schon ein Problem weil das wird
die entscheidende Frage werden im Herbst
und Winter und man jetzt was ist Ihnen
bei der Befragung der des Bundeskanzlers
aufgefallen ist das dritte Mal Kanzler
geworden ist der ist ja auf allen
Fraktions allen möglichen Themen gefragt
worden jeder darf sogar eine Nachfrage
stellen wie
hat er sich da geschlagen oder ist in
etwas Besonderes aufgefallen
ja also ich glaube ich schon geschlage
gut geschlagen heute mich interessierte
schon das außenpolitische und das fand
ich auch interessant in der Nachfrage
tatsächlich nach diesen
Sicherheitsgarantien die wir nicht
wissen was dahinter steckt hatte etwas
Neues gesagt für mich zumindest dass er
sagte es gebe eigentlich keiner weil für
mich sind ja Sicherheitsgarantien ist
ein bisschen bestimmter Begriff und
heute hat er gesagt das wird so wie die
Ukraine sich das vorstellt nicht
aussehen das heißt es wird nicht
gleichwertig mit Artikel 5 NATO also der
Wunsch der maximalwunsch der Ukraine
wird nicht erfüllt das ist für mich
rübergekommen und das war für mich etwas
substanziell neues was aus dem Politik
angeht weil der Abgeordnete Johann
wade-pool von der cduce hat mich genau
die Frage gestellt die sie vor einer
Woche im aus dem gleichen Thema
bestellen können wir gleich noch mal
drauf ja so zögerlich zaudernd die Fuß
kommentierend oder kommunizierend zu
wenig Klarheit der Bundeskanzler das in
den letzten Tagen vielleicht auch heute
etwas entkräften können also ich glaube
dass er in sich insgesamt gut geschlagen
hat also hat er inzwischen auch schon
Routine hat nicht meine das ist ja im
Parlament so ein bisschen so als würde
er im Fernsehen interviewt nicht nur von
mehreren Abgeordneten statt von einem
Moderator Fragen gestellt von den
meisten Abgeordneten
Beispiel zeigen dass da irgendwie
gefragt wird kritisch gefragt wird das
hat er jetzt geübt er hat sehr viele
Interviews gegeben und ähnliche
Antworten hat er dann auch im Parlament
wieder abgespult also sie haben aber
recht beim Thema NATO kann man sagen kam
ein bisschen was neues ich glaube der
Knackpunkt wurde sichtbar als er von der
Linken Fraktion von der Vorsitzenden
Wissler gefragt wurde denn die hat ja
auf die sozialen Ungerechtigkeiten
abgehoben und da muss man einfach sagen
hat die Koalition bisher eigentlich
fatale Fehler gemacht man hat 30
Milliarden ausgegeben an
entlastungspaketen davon sind aber nur
zwei Milliarden bei den wirklich armen
angekommen manche haben gar nichts
gekriegt zum Beispiel Arme Rentner
die 30 Milliarden sind ja noch gar nicht
wirksam geworden die werden wir jetzt
gerade erst ja das stimmt trotzdem wird
das jetzt aber das meiste ist ja so
Prinzip Gießkanne also zum Beispiel
jeder von uns egal wie viel wir an
Steuern zahlen und wie viel wir
verdienen kriegen jetzt irgendwann im
September 300 €, die braucht aber nicht
jeder auch jeder kriegt das 9 € Ticket
nicht jeder braucht 9 € Ticket Tank
Rabatt und so weiter also das ist das
Prinzip Gießkanne aber die Leute die es
wirklich brauchen haben von den 30
Milliarden nur zwei bekommen das ist
jetzt die Berechnung des Paritätischen
Wohlfahrtsverbandes und da hat die Linke
natürlich Fragen gestellt und dazu hatte
natürlich Scholz auch überhaupt Null
Antwort weil es tatsächlich peinlich ist
es ist nicht nur Prinzip Gießkanne ist
offensichtlich der Fall aber so
obendrein auch der Versuch eine
Normalität irgendwie noch zu simulieren
die die nicht mehr da ist also der
Tankrabatt tut so als könne man immer
noch sorgenfrei Autofahren so wie vorher
das halte ich grundsätzlich auch für
falsch also ich teile a ihre Kritik an
der an der Gießkanne es gibt einfach
manche die bedürftiger sind als andere
in dieser Situation und dieser Versuch
uns noch in den wohlstandskokon zu
halten indem wir jahrelang
jahrzehntelang so schön gelebt haben
halte ich im Prinzip auch für falschen
Origin alexander hat gesagt es schadet
nicht wenn führende Politiker und
vielleicht auch die Politik da damit
einhergehende Politik uns klar macht es
wird ungemütlicher es wird ganz sicher
ungemütlicher es wird kälter in den
Wohnungen und an der Zapfsäule kostet
der Spritpreise die wir uns nicht haben
vorstellen können jetzt muss man aber
sagen das war eine Idee von Christian
Lindner diese ganze
für diese Woche aus dem Staub gemacht
hat und der sich dazu nicht mehr
geäußert hat aus naheliegenden privaten
Gründen ein einer Situation ist der
Bundeskanzler auf Temperatur gekommen in
der Befragung der Bundesregierung dazu
braucht es aber immer alles Abgeordneten
der AFD das war Steffen codré gewesen
der den Bundeskanzler nach der
Wirtschafts- und Energiekrise gefragt
hat
und dass diese Aktion ja misst sein und
damit Deutschland ins Elend gestürzt
wird Steffen caudré und danach die
Antwort des Bundeskanzlers warum
Öl embargo PCK Schwedt wir gehen dort
mit den Arbeitskräften unter wenn die
drusspatrasse nicht mehr mit Öl
beliefert wird und das alles sind
Mosaiksteine für die schleichende
Zerstörung unseres Wohlstandes und ja
das ist leider Ausdruck ihrer unsozialen
Politik und wie wollen Sie das den
Bürgern erklären ich halte fest die AFD
ist nicht nur eine rechtspopulistische
Partei sondern auch die Partei Russlands
und das sollten alle zur kennt ihr
nehmen
und ansonsten ist es so dass wir uns ja
genau auf diese Situation vorbereitet
haben wir haben sorgfältige Vorbereitung
getroffen dass wir unsere
Kohleversorgung sicherstellen können mit
Importen aus aller Welt und eben nicht
aus Russland wir treiben wir treffen
Vorsorge dafür dass wir auf die
Ölimporte verzichten können die sind
schon erheblich zurückgegangen und wir
arbeiten daran dass es andere importwege
gibt als die die bisher eingeschlagen
worden sind es wird ihn nicht in Gang
sein dass eine der Raffinerien im Osten
Deutschlands von sich aus längst
entschieden hat sich andere importwege
zu organisieren
es geht ja darum den Menschen die Angst
zu nehmen dass der Herbst und der Winter
ganz schlimm werden war das überzeugend
so wie er da reagiert hat er auf eine
massive Vorhaltung reagiert sehr
tendenzieliös die er mit einem Satz mit
der Partei Russlands abgemauert und dann
hat er ja konkret zu diesem Thema
gesprochen was ich kann diese
Argumentation da eingeordnet werden die
AFD und die Linkspartei sind mit dem
gleichen Vorschlag in den Tag gegangen
nämlich wenn Nord Stream 1 jetzt
gewartet wird und wenn ich wissen ob es
wieder aufgeht machen wir doch Nord
Stream 2 auf das liegt ja fertig in der
Ostsee und das ist natürlich genau die
Debatte die Putin haben will also
deshalb inszeniert er das so mit den
Rohstoffen man muss der Ehrenrettung der
Linkspartei zugute halten dass die
Fraktionsführung den Abgeordneten Ernst
immer in den Vorsitzenden des
energieausschusses der das gesagt hat
192 aufmachen wieder eingefangen hat
also die Linke ist nur die halbe Partei
Russland die AFD aber tatsächlich ganz
die haben sich da völlig auf dieses
Gleis begeben was ich für eine parte
Patriotismus für sich beansprucht für
eine interessante Beobachtung halte und
dann macht Scholz natürlich den Konter
den er da machen kann
wenn Abgeordnete klug nachgefragt hätte
hätten sie vielleicht erinnert an die
Verbindung der SPD mit Russland in den
letzten Jahren aber das war wieder was
anderes Thema gewesen muss man jetzt mal
deutlich sagen ja gut und alles andere
wäre ja auch noch schön diese diese
frühere Liason der SPD der Union ja auch
aber besonders der SPD mit Russland wie
wird das eigentlich gerade in Osteuropa
ist das immer noch ein Thema das
misstrauisch macht auch gegenüber Olaf
Scholz
also es wurde schon sehr wohl
wahrgenommen dass sich die deutsche
politische Elite sage ich mal
mehrfach korrigierte selbst korrigierte
natürlich auch auf Druck aber auch
einfach von der Realität eingeholt
korrigierte das wird schon registriert
dann noch natürlich bleibt ein
Misstrauen da und das ist auch dem
geschuldet dass Deutschland lange sehr
zögerlich handelt also die
Bundesregierung bzw Kanzler hat die Zeit
dann wenn der eingeläutet zu sagen dann
später auch gemacht die aber immer noch
zum Teil nicht eingelöst sind und das
ist auch der Blick aus dem Osten ist
okay in Deutschland da hat man sich halt
gut bequem eingerichtet im Wohlstand und
jetzt hat man Angst davor dass der
Wurststand runter geht unter dem
Schutzschirm der Amerikaner bei uns geht
es jetzt der Wohlstand ist jetzt zweite
Geschichte die erste ist einfach die
Existenz und die Sicherheit und das ist
dieses Spannungsfeld den Olaf Scholz
jetzt schaffen muss zwischen ihnen aus
Politik also über den zu spät nach Kiew
Gefahren aus ihrer Sicht es ist schon
eine komplizierte Sache nach der
Ausladung des Bundespräsidenten da kann
ich auch kann ich auch nachvollziehen
dass es dauern musste ich habe auch sehr
auch kritisch diese Stimme danach dass
man manche gefordert haben warum ist
Polen nicht dabei ich fand es nach so
einem klar konnte kein polnischer
Teilnehmer da bei der Reise dabei sein
das war richtig so wie es war meine
Meinung nach aber ja also spät gefahren
das stimmt aber dennoch Misstrauen
bleibt aber es wird es wird kleiner und
alle erwarten dass das jetzt im Sommer
irgendwie doch vorangeht also ich glaube
wenn es nach dem Sommer so bleibt wie
bisher dann dann wird es irgendwie
schwierig werden für die deutsche auch
für solche emis im Ausland der
Bundeskanzler operiert ja gerade im
Zusammenhang mit der Ukraine respektive
den Waffenlieferungen dahinter mit dem
Argument er sei sehr besonnen oder für
ihn stünde Besonderheit ganz oben ist
das nachvollziehbares Argument oder ist
das ein schutzargument nee also ich
meine es ist nachvollziehbar also ich
glaube auch dass das bei den Deutschen
an sich ganz gut ankommt dass man jetzt
in der Krise jemanden hat der nicht
einfach überstürzt handelt sondern
offenbar nachdenkt wenn man sich jetzt
einfach mal fundamental die strategische
Situation anguckt dann stellt man
folgendes fest Deutschland hat
eigentlich keine Waffen die man in die
Ukraine liefern kann mit Ausnahmen weil
entweder hat die
Bundeswehr gar keine Waffen oder man hat
keine Ersatzteile oder man hat keine
Munition oder aber es sind Waffen die
auch die Amerikaner nicht liefern also
das muss man ja ganz klar sehen beiden
hat durchgesetzt im Kongress dass man 40
Milliarden an Waffen und Hilfe in die
Ukraine liefert aber zwei Sachen sind
nicht dabei keine Kampfpanzer und keine
Kampfflugzeuge so das heißt wenn die
Amerikaner keine Panzer liefern dann ist
das eine Nachricht für Deutschland das
heißt nämlich okay es gehen die
Abstimmung der NATO ist es gehen keine
den restlichen Panzer in die Ukraine
Punkt das heißt was man dann macht und
das macht eben die Bundeswehr ist
Ringtausch das heißt alle sowjetischen
Panzer die noch irgendwo rum stehen ob
in Griechenland in den Tschechien in
Slowenien in Polen werden in die Ukraine
geschoben und dafür kommen die
westlichen Panzer dann in diese Länder
so das ist das was jetzt passiert
werden
angeblicher sehr viel effektiver im
Kampf einzusetzen ich bin kein
Militärexperte als zum Beispiel der
Schützenpanzer Martha und den es ja auch
viel Ärger gibt ist auch Schwennicke
nochmal diese Konsequenz in dieser
Argumentation von Olaf Scholz in Bezug
auf Waffenlieferung erst hieß es
wir würden gerne liefern haben aber
nichts als man dann einige Klumpen noch
auf dem Hof gefunden haben wir gesagt
naja aber da könnt ihr die Ukraine gar
nicht bedienen die sind ja westlichen
Technik gar nicht unterwiesen nachdem
das aber auch noch möglich schien hieß
es dann plötzlich ja wenn wir jetzt
wirklich
kampffähiges gefechtsfähiges Material
liefern dann
könnten die Russen sich auch an
Westeuropa an die naheliegende
NATO-Länder wenn dann also Stichwort
Atomkrieg rote Linie überschreiten und
so weiter war diese diese
Argumentationskette die von der
Bundesregierung auch vor allem von der
SPD und Olaf Scholz kam so überzeugen
das tut mir jetzt leid dass ich da nicht
die Gegenrede halten kann auf Frau
Hermann weil ich es auch so sehe also
wir haben vorhin über schlechte
Kommunikation gesprochen seitens der
Bundesregierung wir können auch über
ziemlich brillante und geniale
Kommunikation sprechen das ist die der
Ukraine die es sehr gut geschafft hat
Deutschland zu markieren sozusagen als
als das Problem und die deutsche
Regierung auch die deutsche
Öffentlichkeit auch die deutsche
Medienöffentlichkeit war sehr willig und
bereit sich da triggern zu lassen also
an der Stelle irgendwie zu sagen ja
irgendwie machen wir es nicht so richtig
und die Argumente die sie aufgeführt
haben der Keller finde ich in
unterschiedlicher Wertigkeit aber auch
alle berücksichtigenswert also kann man
ich auch nicht einfach so beiseite
wischen und tatsächlich ist die ist das
was Deutschland faktisch tut nicht so
groß zu unterscheiden von dem was die
Verbündeten machen aber die deutsche
Regierung ist durch diese sehr
geschickte Kommunikation extrem in die
Defensive gekommen mehr als andere
Länder die auch nicht mehr tun aber mit
dieser Klage nicht so zu leben haben wie
die deutsche Regierung bis hierher ich
glaube das stimmt überhaupt nicht
eigentlich haben wir mal in diesem
Gesetz hier endlich wenn man sich
anguckt wie die Entwicklung ist diese
Debatte mit den Waffen ging doch nicht
los mit der jetzigen Invasion sondern
mit der letzten Invasion also als Putin
die Krim genommen hat und in die
Ostukraine eingefallen ist gab es eine
internationale Debatte was machen wir
jetzt und da war Deutschland in Personen
von Angela Merkel die advokatin errüstet
nicht die Ukraine hoch
große gegenport war der Senator John
McCain in den USA der gesagt hat wir
müssen die Sorte jetzt bewaffnen weil
die geht es sonst an den Kragen und Gott
sei Dank hat diese merkelposition nicht
gehalten weil die Amerikaner die Briten
und die Osteuropäer die Ukraine
ausgerüstet haben und in Berlin ging man
doch davon aus dass die Ukraine in drei
Tagen zusammenklappt deshalb doch die
cr-zeitenwende drei Tage zu spät man
dachte in Berlin sonst hätten die USA
dem Herrn sie denn eigentlich ein
transportangeboten also die USA
offensichtlich auch also wir können uns
ja glaube ich darauf einigen dass Kiew
nicht gefallen ist so und das ist nicht
gefallen weil die Ukraine bewaffnet war
und sie ist nicht von uns bewaffnet
worden und gegen unseren Rat dann hat
Olaf Scholz die zeitenwände gemacht 180
Grad Kehre aber dann war er mit jeder
Ausrüstung hinten dran selbst die
französische Artillerie war schneller da
als unsere das kann man sagen die
Bundeswehr hat nix und
illustrie hat auch nichts aber wir sind
der viertgrößte Waffenexporteur des
Planeten wir haben von Ägypten bis sonst
jede halb seine Diktatur ausgerüstet und
jetzt haben sie eine demokratische in
unserer Nähe und die Anträge liegen im
Bundessicherheitsrat also Olaf Scholz
wollte nicht dass wir an der Spitze der
Bewaffnung der Ukraine stehen dass er
sich immerhin eingereiht hat Gott sei
Dank aber auch die ringtäusche das ist
ja alles noch nicht da also wenn die
Ukraine sich in Sachen Waffen auf uns
verlassen müsste dann wäre er selenski
entweder im Exil oder vom Gericht schon
nun hat aber Ukraine auch die
Sicherheiten von den USA und
Großbritannien 94 bekommen mit dem
budapestimme morandum deshalb natürlich
ist schon auch für mich nachvollziehbar
dass die USA und Großbritannien das
meiste unterm schnellsten liefern und
dass die Polen und Osteuropäer auch
nachliefern und zwar richtig viel
deutlich mehr auch als Deutschland
teilweise aber ebenso geldisches
Material ja aber sie liefen sie
versprochen sie versprachen 1,8
Milliarden Euro im Wert verschiedene
Hilfen und das haben sie geliefert bis
heute bei Deutschland ist es ein Drittel
soweit ich alles was bisher geliefert
wurde bei USA auch aber halt nominal
viel mehr aber die Rolle von USA und
Großbritannien ist natürlich schon auch
erklärbar warum sie so schnell waren und
warum Osteuropa da auch weil sie halten
unmittelbar betroffen sind also wo Herr
Alexander absolut Recht hat muss man
jetzt mal sagen damit ist die
Kontroverse schon wieder vorbei es ist
alleine
in den USA und Großbritannien zu
verdanken dass Kiew nicht angenommen
wurde weil es diese Panzerabwehrraketen
und die luftraketen gab aber das zeigt
auch was die Ukraine jetzt im Augenblick
eigentlich braucht nämlich Artillerie
also der ganze Krieg läuft über
Artillerie und das liefert Deutschland
ja auch also natürlich nur sieben
Haubitzen und so ist alles wenig mir
gibt's aber nicht so diese Panzer werden
ja eigentlich nötig um das verlorene
Gebiet zurück zu erobern und das ist
aber im Moment auch gar nicht die Phase
des Krieges um die es geht das muss man
glaube ich auch alles auseinanderhalten
das ist also komplett ne ich jedenfalls
nicht die ganze Zeit sagen Deutschland
tut nichts und
ich würde gerne da das Thema sich hier
um den Bundeskanzler und Sendung auf den
selbigen zurückkommen Frau Roman jetzt
die waren ja mit Robin Alexander
zusammen in Ellmau gewesen beim G7
Gipfel dieser Gipfel ist ja Deutschland
hat ja dort im Moment den Vorsitz war ja
auch eine Gelegenheit für Olaf Scholz
dem eben das zögerliche das zaudernde
das unentschlossene auch vorausgehen
auch im Ausland diesen Eindruck zu
korrigieren ist in das eigentlich
gelungen hat er auf der internationalen
Bühne gesagt dass er a ein verlässlicher
Partner ist dass er aber auch
gleichzeitig als Vorsitzender der G7 für
Geschlossenheit des Westens sorgen kann
dass erst nach außen zumindestens so
kommuniziert wird und dass man eben
versucht in dieser schwierigen Situation
tatsächlich an einem Strang zu ziehen
ist ihm das als Gastgeber in Ellmau
gelungen ja wenn man auf die Ergebnisse
schaut dann muss man sagen dann schauen
da gibt es wieder besser als vielleicht
erwartet also am Ende gab es sehr viele
Sachen also auf ganz verschiedenen
Gebiet was so ein bisschen im Wege stand
war das Kommunikationsproblem irgendwann
was mich bisschen überrascht hat dass
das so ein Überhang dann auf am Ende
genommen hat das war pech für den
Bundeskanzler nicht ganz unverschuldet
in diesem Moment aber ja ich würde sagen
der gibt bei dem Gipfel
dann gab es gut gute Ergebnisse was
natürlich auch auffällig war tatsächlich
und das wurde auch gefragt in der
Konferenz dass sehr viele Sachen nicht
von dem Bundeskanzler verkündet wurden
sondern die sprechen jetzt auf die
Abschlusspressekonferenz an dort hat
haben sie Rosalia romanic dem
Bundeskanzler eine Frage gestellt die in
der Reaktion ziemliche Wellen geschlagen
hat wir schauen uns das noch mal an es
geht ganz schnell und kurz wie man das
von Olaf Scholz gewohnt ist
Deutscher Welle Herr Bundeskanzler die
G7 haben bekannten sich sehr
ausdrücklich zu den sicherheitsgar für
die Ukraine auch nach dem Krieg könnten
sie konkretisieren welche
Sicherheitsgarantien das sind ja
könnte ich
das
alexander hat dieser Vorgang den ja
manche auch als arrogantes abmeiern des
Bundeskanzlers bezeichnet haben hat er
nur in der journalistenblase Wellen
geschlagen oder ist da mehr hängen
geblieben dieser Auftritt wie gesagt der
ja zumindest in den sozialen Netzwerken
eine große Rolle gespielt hat wie könnte
man jetzt die Konsequenzen die Folgen
daraus bewerten also ich finde da
sollten wir Journalisten uns jetzt nicht
so wichtig nehmen also auch zum Gipfel
passiert schon noch mehr als als was er
nach einer Pressekonferenz passiert
das Interessante ist diese Dinge auch
die kommunikativen Ereignisse haben
immer ein realen politischen Vorlauf
also ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel 2015
war ja schon mal der Gipfel in Ellmau da
war Merkel ganz stark neben Obama und so
weiter also das stieg sie richtig zur
weltenlenkerin auf und der politische
Hintergrund war das Merkel vorher ihre
Euro Rettungspolitik verändert hatte
vorher sahst du aus als ob Deutschland
vielleicht Griechenland aus dem Euro
wirft die Amerikaner waren sehr
skeptisch sehr dagegen und das haben
Merkel Schäuble in letzter Sekunde nicht
gemacht und der deshalb dann in
Ellmau die Erhöhung also sozusagen so
und dann waren die G7 und die G20 lange
davon
geprägt das Tram verrückt spielte also
Merkels Aufgabe war sozusagen Trump
irgendwie bei der Stange zu halten
manchmal hat er auch das kommuniki
unterschrieben und auf dem Rückflug sich
anders überlegt und gesagt mache ich
doch nicht so und jetzt hatten wir
sozusagen eigentlich eine klassische
Situation ein amerikanischen Präsidenten
der nicht verrückt ist und ein deutscher
Präsident der gut mit ihm
zusammenarbeitet was für Scholz spricht
dass er das tut aber ist dann natürlich
auch nicht ganz tolle Show von daher
finde ich diese Konstellation kann man
ihn wirklich nicht angreifen diese
Reaktion von Scholz auf Journalisten
Fragen die ist ja nicht neu es gab eine
ganze Reihe von Kolleginnen und von
Kollegen von uns die sich schon geärgert
haben dass sie nicht ernst genommen
scheinbar nicht ernst genommen wurden
bei Fragen an ihnen bei verschiedenen
Pressekonferenzen bei verschiedenen
Presseterminen ist das ist das eine
Methode ist das eine Taktik eine
Strategie oder ist das auch manchmal
Unbeholfenheit also es ist ja schön dass
die Kollegin anwesend ist sie macht auf
mich jetzt auch keinen traumatisierten
Eindruck durch dieses Erlebnis man hat
ja auch tatsächlich die Frage wenn ich
eine Frage stelle wenn ich eine Antwort
haben die Frage ist die Respekt die
Respekt also mir gegenüber hörte man
auch da war ja dann auch Gelächter da
ich glaube er hält das tatsächlich für
witzig er meint das auch witzig das ist
so eine eigene weiß ich nicht
hanseatischer Humor der leider nicht
überall gleichermaßen verstanden wird
und dann dann hat er natürlich diese Art
von Humor hat schon eine
Note von von
Hochmut ja
und ja dann versteht es ja eine so eine
so aber da geht es mir wie Robin
Alexander also das muss man jetzt auch
nicht alles dann so wie hat man einer
gesagt hoch sterilisieren also das ist
eine Situation die
die ist markant da kann man sich auch
ein bisschen dran abarbeiten aber wir
sollten es dann auch wieder gut sein
lassen ich glaube die Frage die dahinter
steht ist wie entsteht in Politik
Vertrauen und da haben Scholz und Habeck
komplett unterschiedliche Analysen Olaf
Scholz ist da sehr klassisch wie Merkel
oder wenn Sie wollen Bismarck hat mal
gesagt Gesetze sind wie Wurst die Leute
sollen nicht merken wie sie gemacht
werden also Scholz hat die Idee was wir
im politischen Berlin machen das geht
erstmal kein was an bis es fertig ist
dann verkühlen wir es und dann wird es
debattiert und habe gerade die Idee
Vertrauen entsteht indem ich die Leute
mitnehme nicht nur in die Prozesse
sondern auch in die eigene Seele und
sein eigenes Fraktion am offenen Herzen
sozusagen genau
und und habe ist dann vielleicht ein
bisschen postmodern und was jetzt
wirklich in der deutschen Gesellschaft
langfristig also habe kommt gerade bei
den Journalisten besser an aber was in
der deutschen Gesellschaft langfristig
funktioniert weil merkel hatte auch
diesen zurückgenommenen Stil und die
Leute haben es gemocht also da ist das
wissen wir noch nicht was ich am Ende
auch von Annalena baerbock den Rang
etwas ablaufen in der wir sind immer
noch bei der Performance das ganze ja
also ich glaube
das ist eine gewisse Größe von Scholz
und wird die Ampel am Ende retten dass
er in der Lage ist die anderen glänzen
zu lassen also er hat ja jetzt da schon
mehrere große Selbstdarsteller in seinem
Kabinett also nicht nur Haarwerk sondern
Annalena baerbock und dann natürlich
auch Christian Lindner der muss ja auch
irgendwie glänzen und da ist es
eigentlich gut dass ich Scholz
zurücknehmen kann weil sonst gäbe es da
auf der Bühne Chaos und dann muss man
glaube ich auch noch bedenken das Habeck
nicht der Kanzler ist also habe
profitiert davon dass er letztlich wenn
es um die Gesamtverantwortung geht in
der wahrn der Bevölkerung in der zweiten
Reihe steht und dann kann man natürlich
auch das Volk an den eigenen Gedanken
teilhaben lassen und an den eigenen
zweifeln weil ja klar ist im Ende und am
Zweifel entscheidet der Kanzler wenn
habe Kanzler wäre glaube ich müsste er
diesen Stil komplett und sofort ändern
was ich ihm zutrauen würde nicht also
ist er Habeck ist nicht darauf abonniert
jetzt diesen Stil zu fahren aber das
geht nur in der zweiten Reihe
wenn wir vielleicht auf ein anderes
Thema noch kommen wo aber der Kanzler
auch eine wichtige Rolle spielen wird
und spielen muss dass uns neben Ukraine
und dem drohenden Winter auch
beschäftigt ist Corona hat ja auch etwas
mit Herbst und Winter zu tun
wie agiert er da im Moment eigentlich
oder wie glücklich agiert da hat er ja
hinter sich eine ganze Reihe von
Politikern aus der und Politikerin aus
der Ampel
die von Alarmismus bis Verharmlosung
alles im Repertoire haben was das Thema
pandemie-maskenpflicht Schulschließungen
Impfungen so weiter überhaupt vorsieht
ist er da klug geht er da klug vor in
dieser ich muss ja da immer an die Szene
denken als er die Minister SPD seit ich
vorgestellt hat und bei Karl Lauterbach
gesagt hat ihr wolltet ihn ihr bekommt
ihn das war ja schon auch so ein
spezieller Humor ja und hat aber
natürlich im Subtext gehabt also mein
dringender Wunsch war das nicht
und nun hat sich Karl Lauterbach da
tatsächlich
im Moment so ein bisschen zum Problem
werden entwickelt weil sich wiederum die
Koalitionspartner vor allem die FDP sehr
stark an seiner Position abarbeiten will
als sie gerade die Frage stellen wie
agiert Corona entschuldigt mir geht der
schwierig wie agiert der Kanzler
eigentlich in Sachen Corona habe ich
mich gefragt ja lackiert er da
eigentlich also ich kann da keine
kein Aktion feststellen sondern es
findet bei anderen Stadt aber und das
ist dann schon wieder auch sein Problem
ich räume ein ich hätte gedacht dass die
dass die Unterschiede zwischen
Grünen und der FDP geringer sind als man
gedacht hat weil sie soziokulturell gar
nicht so weit auseinander sind
inhaltlich sind sie eben doch sehr sehr
stark auseinander und deswegen hat er
mir diesen das schon ein sehr spezielles
mobile diese diese Ampelkoalition die
sehr leicht
in Unruhe Gerät zumal wenn dann die eine
der beiden kleineren
Koalitionsfraktionen oder Parteien
ziemlich gut da steht den Umfragen und
die anderen die andere die FDP nicht das
bringt Unruhe also da ist in der Statik
schon ganz schön viel
ja labil und Corona es ist eine der
Treiber dieser Labilität innerhalb der
Koalition die Frage ob in diese
Labilität da im Spätjahr auf die Füße
fallen wird er hat sich ja einen Satz
Corona rausgepresst in den letzten Tagen
hat gesagt also gut mit der
maskenpflicht das kann sein dass die
wieder umfangreicher kommt aber
Schulschließungen lockdowns das sieht er
eigentlich auch nicht er hat sich alles
offengelassen unterschätzte vielleicht
die Brisanz des Themas für die Ampel
glaube er ist da ein bisschen auch ein
gebranntes Kind weil er hat ja einen
corona-akzent versucht zu setzen immer
gesagt hat wir machen eine Impfpflicht
und damit ist er gleich spektakulär
krachen gegangen oder hat er die
Mehrheit nicht zusammengekriegt und
generell ist ja Corona so ein bisschen
jetzt ein toxisches Thema also egal ob
das Team Vorsicht oder das Team Freiheit
also jeder Politiker der in den letzten
Jahren zu oft mit Corona im Fernsehen
war stehen gerade schlecht da und
deshalb lässt Scholz das Thema liegen
das ist kann man vielleicht auch
begründen weil es gerade eine Menge
andere Dinge gibt nur wenn man sich
jetzt anguckt wie die Ampel den Prozess
aufgesetzt hat wir haben ja Corona ein
corona-regime das gesetzlich am 23
September ausläuft dann braucht man was
neues da sind nachher Sommerpause glaube
ich zwei Sitzungswochen und wenn man
sich jetzt überlegt wann die letzte
Herbst winterwelle losging dann kann man
sich ja schon denken dass wir das wieder
sehen werden und das scheint mir alles
arg auf Kante genäht und die FDP hat ja
diesen Trick schon mal gemacht die haben
mir schon letzte Mal die Gesetze
programmiert dass sie automatisch
auslaufen und dann setzen sich dahin und
sagen Lauterbach du kannst in 40
Talkshows gehen unsere Stimmen kriegst
du nicht und so ein bisschen hat es den
einen Anschein als wenn es jetzt wieder
so läuft ja aber ich glaube also du hast
sie haben absolut recht aber ich glaube
dass die FDP aufpassen muss das hat sich
nämlich schon in NRW gezeigt dass die
Rentner die ja oft FDP gewählt haben
stinksauer waren weil sie das Gefühl
hatten dass sie durch diese Freiheit
nirgendwo mehr Masken und so selber
existenziell gefährdet sind und wenn
jetzt im Herbst eine coronawelle kommt
und die FDP dann immer so tut ja wieso
wo ist das Problem wir machen hier
nichts das kann unglaublich gefährlich
sein so das heißt Sie müssen gucken dass
nicht hinterher die vollen
Intensivbetten an ihnen kleben bleiben
und dazu noch einen Satz der zeigt weil
das vorhin schon Thema war wie
existenziell die FDP in Gefahr ist zum
ersten Mal in NRW hat man ja bei
Wahlanalysen gesehen dass hunderttausend
Leute von der FDP direkt zu den Grünen
gegangen sind und früher gab es da eine
Wand also da gab es sozusagen keinerlei
so zu kulturellen austaus den gibt es
jetzt und da muss die FDP wahnsinnig
aufpassen dass nicht alle das Gefühl
haben die spinnen ja total also mir
passiert sehr selten dass ich einer
Meinung mit Burkhard Hirsch bin aber
einer der beiden alt Forderungen die
dann auch immer gerne in den Talkshows
in Fragen die die FDP betreffen gefragt
werden und er hat es so benannt er hat
genau das gesagt die die FDP wird mir im
corona-kurs
Schiffbruch erleiden oder hat deswegen
so eine Delle in den Umfragen ich glaube
da ist was dran wie ist denn die
bisherige Bilanz des Bundeskanzlers es
ist die Unzufriedenheit die viele haben
oder auch in der Ampelkoalition mit dem
was sie bisher gemacht hat ist die
gerechtfertigt tut man ihm Unrecht was
kann man nach sieben Monaten etwas sagen
noch mal auf Corona zurückzukommen dass
es tatsächlich dahin gebranntes Thema
also wenn gerade für ihn auch speziell
das verstehe ich dass er jetzt erwartet
auch wie sich Corona entwickeln muss man
müssen wir auch alle sagen wie wissen
dass die Zahlen hoch geht aber wir
wissen nicht wie signifikant gefährlich
das jetzt sein wird das weiß niemand und
möglicherweise wird darauf so ein
bisschen auch ist das einkalkuliert die
Bilanz insgesamt naja es ist schon jetzt
ein krisenkanzler nach ein paar Monaten
das war die Frau Merkel erst nach paar
Jahren
ja also das glaube ich ich bin da auch
bei Romina Alexander das ist halt die
Frage wie sehen die das und wie sieht
das die Bevölkerung und ich glaube auf
lange Sicht müssen wir schauen ob wie
die Werte dann tatsächlich am Ende des
Jahres aussehen wenn die Krisen auch
sich entfalten wir wissen dass sie jetzt
kommen aber
wie das wie sich das anfühlt das wissen
wir tatsächlich erst im Herbst und
Winter und das wird dann entscheidend
sein wie performt an Olaf Scholz und wie
geht er halt damit um wir kommunizierte
wie verkauft er tatsächlich die
Maßnahmen das kann man glaube ich heute
nach diesem sechs sieben Monaten finde
ich die Bilanz nicht schlecht am Ende ja
wie befand Olaf Scholz im Herbst oder
was kommt auf ihn zu Ukraine Gaskrise
Inflation das kann keiner so richtig
einschätzen mögliche Rezession
klimaschutzfragen Corona dann sind auch
die ganzen Wohltaten weg vom Tank Rabatt
bis zum 9 euro-ticket ist er den
Herausforderungen gewachsen wird er ihn
gewachsen sein also ich finde das wäre
unseriös darüber jetzt ein Urteil zu
geben weil das zeigt sich ja erst noch
und ich finde er hat natürlich große
Vorteile er ist ein sehr erfahrener
Politiker ist auch ein krisenerfahrener
Politiker und das klingt jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen spießig aber
Politik hat auch was Hand ähnliches und
wir haben ja in so mehreren anderen
Ländern gesehen wo Leute die sehr
expressiv drauf sind in so Ämter
gekommen sind dass das auch nicht immer
super war also dass jemand weiß wie
funktioniert der EU-Rat wie funktioniert
die Sozialpartnerschaft in Deutschland
wie funktionieren auch Finanzmärkte das
ist erstmal kein Nachteil das spricht
sehr für ihn und die Bewährungsprobe
kommt noch und die Frage ist auch woran
messen wir ihn wenn wir ihn an seinen
Umfragewerten der SPD gerade messen dann
läuft es sicherlich nicht gut aber das
muss ja nicht das Kriterium vor Politik
sein kann ja auch sagen hat er von
unserem
volksschaden abgewendet oder nicht und
da kommt jetzt die große Bewährungsprobe
die Leute wollen den Bundeskanzler nicht
nur vertrauen sie müssen ihm eigentlich
auch vertrauen können
sind sie da im Moment oder ist da stolz
auf einem guten Weg also ich glaube ja
seine persönlichen Umfragewerte sind ja
nicht schlecht die sind wird sehr viel
besser als die der SPD also ich bin
jetzt nicht dass Olaf Scholz persönlich
wahnsinnig hektisch werden muss und das
ist übrigens seine allergrößte Stärke er
wird nicht hektisch also er ist jemand
das hat ja auch der ganze Wahlkampf
gezeigt der in der Lage ist schlechte
Umfragewerte zu ertragen und der
strategisch denkt und zwar vom Ende her
und nicht immer situativ im Moment und
deswegen
würde ich ihm jetzt mal zutrauen eine
Krise tatsächlich zu bestehen und auch
zu bewältigen Einsatz abzubinden genauso
außerdem darf man in Deutschland den
kanzlerbonus nicht unterschätzen und wir
sollten uns alle noch mal erinnern er
ist eigentlich ein bisschen aus Versehen
auch Bundeskanzler geworden nicht
wirklich aus eigener Kraft denn die
anderen zwei anderen länger baerbock und
Armin Laschet haben es richtig
vermasselt Armin Laschet hätte gut
Bundeskanzler werden können
aber dieses Amt hat eine enorme gravitas
in Deutschland und wenn er die nutzt
dann dann dann hat er diesen
kanzlerbonus und kann ihn auch für die
Wiederwahl damals war im Wahlkampf noch
nicht gewesen Kanzler sondern
offensichtlich auch Krisen Gewinner ich
bedanke mich bei Rosalia Romania bei
Ulrike Herrmann bei Christoph
Schwennicke und bei Robin Alexander
Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer
morgen in der Phönix Runde wanken der
Weltmacht USA kommt Trump zurück
jetzt folgt Phönix der Tag mit Constanze
abratzte darin unter anderem die
Pressekonferenz zur Bilanz des
bisherigen Wiederaufbaus nach der
Hochwasserkatastrophe im Ahrtal in der
nächsten Woche jetzt sich dieses
schlimme Ereignis zum ersten Mal bleiben
Sie bei uns
[Musik]